oh there you are i thought i'd lost you
oh sorry i may have taken a few minutes
to try out a futon it's a young woman's
game okay
where do we stand i think we have
everything yes oh except the ladybug
nightlife for lily
haley your whole life is oh i got him
okay great i'll see you in line
yes ronald i not only found it i got the
last one
yes the ladybug not the turtle
i also got the doll so i'm all set i'm
gonna leave in five
or maybe you just want paper paper paper
just paper all the way yeah haley
too late to change my mind
sir would you like me to hold your
merchandise up at the register while you
finish shopping oh aren't you a dream
pack a gum
and one more
pack of gum
[Music]
people drop in this time of year you
know
excuse me guys pardon me sorry excuse me
nightlight you were looking for a ma'am
bring her up madison thank you
there you go
you're leaving me alone here no no no i
it'll uh
it'll just take me two minutes i need to
get jay's super secret special gift
great first he'd lose me in the grocery
store now i'm in a deserted parking lot
why don't you just put a sign on me that
says free kid
i think that might be him you don't know
the guy we're meeting
that's how craigslist works total
strangers sell you things like signed
vintage baseball cards that make your
father-in-law respect you for an
afternoon i don't like the looks of this
guy
he looks like everybody else great we
can just sell out to the police sketch
artist
yeah joe dimaggio phil dunphy but i get
that a lot
kidding i'm your guy
can i see the cash yes can i
can i see the card
mint condition
that's why i want another 50. i only
have the 200.
yeah deal's off then come on it's
christmas
at our house it's a long story
225. i just spent all my cash on
groceries fine but i'm taking the
butterball i don't know about that
that's it i'm getting mother's little
helper what my monkeys are stunking for
emergencies this isn't an emergency
oh now it is
i thought he was going to snatch me
oh
what'd he say i think he said a
butterball's a
turkey was reaching for the turkey oh
well we can't give you our turkey
here's the
money
oh
[Applause]
garbage
huh never saw this before
an angel for my angels love mom oh
that's beautiful
it smells like moth balls just like nana
luke
thank merry christmas just give it up
hey hey
don't beat yourself up i do that like
once a week the good news is we never
have to come back here
watch out
the tree yeah i can't watch
look ah yes i said look you told me
already i did it right
never look back never
maybe we can salvage it
are you okay papi yeah
good that's because we had our guardian
angel i had five
[Music]
[Music]
you